History looping through your cold machines, warm, where humming's your soft set, get carried through the tangled wires, cold machines, warm ghosts, you sing, and something in me shakes, I'm holding on to where. Hi guys, this is Joel with the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast, and thank you for listening to Part 3 of Psychotherapy on the Couch, a Psycho History of American Psychology. What psychology can see, what it can't see, and why it has trouble telling the difference. In my opinion, the other half of the revolution, the half of women's liberation movement,
历史在你的冷机器中循环，温暖，嗡嗡声是你柔和的背景，被带入纠缠的电线中，冷机器，温暖的幽灵，你歌唱，我内心深处有什么在颤抖，我紧紧抓住那个地方。大家好，我是Joel，这是Taproot Therapy Collective播客，感谢收听《沙发上的心理治疗》第三部分：美国心理学的心理历史。心理学能看到什么，不能看到什么，以及为什么它难以区分两者。在我看来，这场革命的另一半，即妇女解放运动的那一半，
is the boys in my country and in yours wearing their hair long. And those boys who are wearing their hair long are saying, No to the masculine mystique. They are saying no to that brutal, sadistic, tight-lipped, crew-cut, you know, Prussian, big muscle, you know, Ernest Hemingway, kill bears when there are no bears to kill, and napalm all the children in Vietnam and Cambodia to prove that I'm a man, you know,
是我国和你们国家的男孩们留着长发。那些留着长发的男孩们在说，不，拒绝男性气质的神秘感。他们拒绝那种残酷、虐待、守口如瓶、平头、你知道的，普鲁士式的、大块头、你知道的，欧内斯特·海明威式的，在没有熊可杀的时候去杀熊，在越南和柬埔寨用凝固汽油弹轰炸所有孩子来证明我是个男人，你知道的，
and be dominant and superior to everyone concerned, and never show any softness. Well, these boys that are wearing their hair long are saying, no. I don't have to be all that crew cut and tight lip. I don't have to be dominant and superior to anyone. I don't have to have big muscles
并且对所有相关的人表现得专横和优越，从不表现出任何柔情。好吧，这些留着长发的男孩们在说，不。我不必非得那样平头和守口如瓶。我不必对任何人表现得专横和优越。我不必拥有大块肌肉，
because there aren't any bears to kill. I don't have to, you know, kill anybody to prove anything. I can be tender and I can be sensitive and I can be compassionate and I can admit sometimes that I'm afraid and I can even cry. And I am a man. I am my own. I am my own.
因为根本没有熊可以杀。我不必，你知道，为了证明什么而去杀任何人。我可以温柔，我可以敏感，我可以富有同情心，我可以承认有时我会害怕，我甚至可以哭泣。而我是一个男人。我是我自己的。我是我自己的。
man and that man who is strong enough to be geno, that is a new man, and he is the other half of this revolution. In 1963, Betty Friedan published the feminine mystique and gave name to something that had been floating through American consciousness for nearly two decades. She called it the problem that has no name. And Friedan was writing about suburban housewives, women who had everything that the culture told them that they should want, husbands, children, modern homes filled with labor-saving appliances.
男人，那个足够强大到可以成为真实自我的人，那是一个新男人，他是这场革命的另一半。1963年，贝蒂·弗里丹出版了《女性的奥秘》，并为某种在近二十年来一直漂浮在美国人意识中的东西命名。她称之为“没有名字的问题”。弗里丹写的是郊区的家庭主妇，那些拥有文化告诉她们应该想要的一切的女性：丈夫、孩子、装满省力家电的现代住宅。
and these women should have been happy. But the magazines told them that they were happy. The advertisements showed them smiling, and yet in interview after interview, Bradan found something else entirely. A vague and persistent dissatisfaction, an on way, a sense that something was missing,
这些女性本应该感到幸福。杂志告诉她们她们很幸福。广告展示她们在微笑，然而在一次又一次的采访中，弗里丹发现了完全不同的东西。一种模糊而持续的不满，一种倦怠感，一种缺失了什么的感觉，
a feeling that there must be more to life than this. And the housewives were not the only ones feeling it. Their husbands commuting to corporate jobs, climbing ladders whose tops they could never quite see, felt it too. And so did their children, The baby boomers, growing up in communities that were physically comfortable and psychologically sterile.
一种觉得生活一定不止于此的感觉。感到这种情绪的不仅仅是家庭主妇。她们的丈夫每天通勤去公司上班，攀爬着永远看不到顶端的阶梯，也感受到了这一点。他们的孩子，婴儿潮一代，在物质上舒适但心理上贫瘠的社区中长大，也是如此。
And so did the artists, writers, and intellectuals watching American culture become increasingly homogenized, increasingly optimized, and increasingly empty. This was a strange achievement of post-war America. Unprecedented material abundance, coexisting with unprecedented spiritual vacancy. And the nation had won the war, built the suburbs, filled the garages with automobiles, and the kitchens with appliances, the economy was booming, and the middle class was expanding. and yet something was wrong and something was missing. This episode is about that void and the various attempts to fill it.
艺术家、作家和知识分子看着美国文化变得越来越同质化、越来越优化、越来越空虚，也是如此。这是战后美国的一个奇怪成就。前所未有的物质丰裕，与前所未有的精神空虚并存。国家赢得了战争，建起了郊区，车库里停满了汽车，厨房里装满了电器，经济繁荣，中产阶级在扩张。然而，有些地方不对劲，有些东西缺失了。这一集就是关于那种空虚以及填补它的各种尝试。
It is about what psychology did during the three decades of American Triumph and what it failed to do. It's about the genuine seekers who tried to find alternatives to the emptiness, and a couple hucksters along the way, against the machinery that absorbed their seeking and sold it back to them as a lifestyle, and it's about the modalities that emerged, the theories that competed, and the fundamental question that nobody wanted to answer. What happens when human beings are given everything except? meaning. To understand the psychological condition of post-war America, you have to understand what
它是关于心理学在美国胜利的三十年里做了什么，以及它没能做什么。它是关于那些试图寻找空虚替代品的真正寻求者，以及沿途的一些骗子，对抗那些吸收了他们的寻求并将其作为一种生活方式卖回给他们的机器，它是关于出现的模式、竞争的理论，以及没人想回答的根本问题。当人类被给予了一切，唯独没有意义时，会发生什么？要理解战后美国的心理状况，你必须理解什么，
was actually built and why. Between 1945 and 1960, the physical landscape of American life was transformed more rapidly and thoroughly than at any point in the nation's history before. 16 million veterans returned from the war. And while the nation was ostensibly grateful for their service, the political and economic establishment was absolutely terrified of their reintegration. The memory of the Great Depression was fresh. The last thing that anyone wanted was 16 million unemployed young men flooding back into the labor market and potentially sparking a European-style communist revolution right here at home. But beneath this, fear lay an even darker and more unspeakable realization.
实际上是被建造出来的，以及为什么。在1945年到1960年之间，美国生活的物理景观被改造的速度和彻底程度超过了该国历史上任何时期。1600万退伍军人从战争中归来。虽然国家表面上对他们的服务表示感谢，但政治和经济体制对他们的重新融入感到极度恐惧。大萧条的记忆还很新鲜。没人想要的是1600万失业的年轻人涌回劳动力市场，并可能在本土引发一场欧洲式的共产主义革命。但在这种恐惧之下，隐藏着一个更黑暗、更难以言说的认识。
As Noam Chomsky pointed out, it was not Franklin Delano Roosevelt's New Deal that got America out of the Great Depression. The new deal looked like it might have been working, but the experiment was never really run. How could we ever truly tell if it hadn't been the war? because what broke the back of the economic terror was the massive blood-soaked industrial engine of World War II and the total war manufacturing capacity that America had adopted in order to fight the war. And this created a terrifying shadow that still haunts America to this day. The underlying and unspoken realization that the American economic machine might actually need an existential threat to survive, and that when it doesn't have one, it might seek to manufacture one.
正如诺姆·乔姆斯基指出的那样，并不是富兰克林·德拉诺·罗斯福的“新政”让美国走出了大萧条。新政看起来似乎奏效了，但这个实验从未真正运行过。我们怎么能真正确定如果不是因为战争会怎样呢？因为打破经济恐怖脊梁的是二战那台巨大的、血腥的工业引擎，以及美国为了打赢战争而采用的全面战争制造能力。这创造了一个至今仍困扰着美国的恐怖阴影。那种潜在的、未说出口的认识：美国经济机器可能实际上需要一个生存威胁才能生存，而当它没有威胁时，它可能会试图制造一个。
It might require the conditions of total war to maintain a functioning economy, and perhaps we were only able to exist in opposition to an enemy. And so we simulated the conditions of total war for most of the rest of our existence. We needed the Cold War and we needed the myth of the Soviet threat to justify the terrifying machinery of the new military industrial complex, to keep the factories open and to quiet our own psychological ghosts. And this was a massive tragic hinge point in American history. When the war ended, we had a choice. We had the economic surplus and the technological power to completely revision the American dream.
它可能需要全面战争的条件来维持一个运作良好的经济，也许我们只能在与敌人的对立中存在。于是，我们在余下的大部分时间里模拟了全面战争的条件。我们需要冷战，我们需要苏联威胁的神话来证明新的军事工业复合体那台恐怖机器的合理性，以保持工厂开放并平息我们自己的心理幽灵。这是美国历史上一个巨大的悲剧性转折点。战争结束时，我们有一个选择。我们拥有经济盈余和技术力量来彻底重塑美国梦。
We could have built a society where meaning was derived from specialized craft, from deep organic community, or from a shared civic purpose. And instead, we defined the American dream as a suburban home, a perfectly manicured square of grass, the ability to eat eight servings of red meat a day, and the ability to buy everything that you needed without ever having to produce anything yourself. We hollowed out the core of human experience,
我们本可以建立一个社会，让意义源于专业技能、深厚的有机社区或共同的公民目标。相反，我们将美国梦定义为郊区的房子、一块修剪得完美的草坪、每天吃八份红肉的能力，以及无需自己生产任何东西就能买到所需一切的能力。我们掏空了人类体验的核心，
and because this new dream contained largely no meaning, we replaced the soul with the myth of normal. a baseline of acceptable consumption that we would be forced to frantically reinvent every 10 years just to keep the economic engine running. The suburbs themselves were a product of this paranoia. The GI Bill and the Federal Highway Act of 1956, officially titled the National System of Interstate and Defense Highways, poured billions into creating this new reality. It wasn't just a consumer utopia, it was an explicitly military strategy.
因为这个新梦想基本上不包含任何意义，我们用“正常”的神话取代了灵魂。一种可接受消费的基准，我们被迫每10年疯狂地重塑一次，只是为了让经济引擎运转。郊区本身就是这种偏执的产物。《退伍军人权利法案》和1956年的《联邦公路法案》（正式名称为《州际和国防公路国家系统》）投入了数十亿美元来创造这种新现实。这不仅仅是一个消费乌托邦，它更是一项明确的军事战略。
And dense urban centers were nuclear targets. A single Soviet bomb could eliminate millions of workers. crippling American industrial capacity. The solution was dispersal, spread the population outward, in a low-density suburb connected by highways that could serve as evacuation routes. The animization of the American family was literal, state-sponsored nuclear defense. The houses were nearly identical, Cape Cod-style 750 square feet in a patch of grass, and while they offered central heating and indoor plumbing, they aggressively eradicated public space. There were no town squares. There were no walkable commercial districts. As the philosopher Hanna Arendt noted,
密集的城市中心是核目标。一枚苏联炸弹就能消灭数百万工人，瘫痪美国的工业能力。解决方案是分散，将人口向外扩散，通过可以作为疏散路线的公路连接起来的低密度郊区。美国家庭的原子化是字面意义上的，即国家支持的核防御。房子几乎一模一样，科德角风格，750平方英尺，带一块草坪，虽然它们提供了中央供暖和室内管道，但它们积极地消灭了公共空间。没有城镇广场。没有可步行的商业区。正如哲学家汉娜·阿伦特所指出的，
public space is the essential theater of human appearance, the realm where political action and true community occur. The suburb aggressively eradicated this space, and later theorists of new urbanism, like friend of the podcast, Leon Creer, would correctly identify this spatial segregation as an architectural pathology, a deliberate severing of civic life that isolated the individual within a private domestic form. Well, it's sort of a stupid job, really. There's nothing interesting about it at all. What do you do it for, then? Maybe Frank doesn't like being questioned by this. Oh, okay, okay, okay, I know. It's none of my business. And besides, I know the answer. You want to play a house, you've got to have a job. You want to play a very nice house, very sweet house.
公共空间是人类展现自我的基本舞台，是政治行动和真正社区发生的领域。郊区积极地消灭了这个空间，后来新城市主义的理论家，比如播客的朋友莱昂·克里尔，会正确地将这种空间隔离识别为一种建筑病理学，一种蓄意切断公民生活、将个人孤立在私人家庭形式中的行为。好吧，这确实是一份愚蠢的工作。它一点意思都没有。那你为什么还要做呢？也许弗兰克不喜欢被这样质问。哦，好吧，好吧，好吧，我知道了。这不关我的事。再说，我知道答案。你想玩过家家，你就得有一份工作。你想玩一个非常好的房子，非常甜蜜的房子。
Then you've got to have a job you don't like. Anyone comes along and says, what do you do it for? He's probably on a... Four hour pass from the state funny farm. This was a society that was drunk on the illusion of absolute engineering. They had split the atom. They were aiming rockets at the moon. And the American domestic space was rapidly being flooding with a techno fix. The automatic washing machine, the television set, and eventually the microwave oven.
那你必须有一份你不喜欢的工作。如果有人走过来问，你为什么要做这个？他可能是一个……从州立疯人院出来的四小时通行证持有者。这是一个沉醉于绝对工程学幻觉的社会。他们分裂了原子。他们瞄准了月球发射火箭。而美国的家庭空间正迅速被技术修复所淹没。自动洗衣机、电视机，最终是微波炉。
The prevailing cultural ideology was that the human struggle was obsolete. Any problem no matter how complex or emotional could be solved with the push of a button. The atomic bomb did not just split the atom. It split the timeline of human consciousness. For the entirety of human history, despite plagues and wars, there was always an underlying assumption of continuity. There would always be a tomorrow, and suddenly for the first time, humanity possessed the technology to instantly delete itself and started living only for the future.
盛行的文化意识形态是人类的斗争已经过时了。任何问题，无论多么复杂或情绪化，都可以通过按下一个按钮来解决。原子弹不仅分裂了原子。它分裂了人类意识的时间线。在整个人类历史上，尽管有瘟疫和战争，但始终存在一种连续性的基本假设。总会有明天，而突然间，人类第一次拥有了瞬间自我毁灭的技术，并开始只为未来而活。
The looming shadow of the bomb effectively broke traditional psychoanalysis. The Freudian model required time. It required years on the couch, patiently excavating early childhood memories to slowly, methodically construct a stable future. But how do you sell the promise of a stable future to a generation of children doing duck and cover drills? What else is that psychoanalysis's large appeal had always been that it let you peel back the layers and stare at this big sexy secret beneath the world,
炸弹笼罩的阴影有效地打破了传统的精神分析。弗洛伊德模型需要时间。它需要在沙发上躺上几年，耐心地挖掘童年早期的记忆，以缓慢、有条不紊地构建一个稳定的未来。但你如何向一代正在进行“卧倒并掩护”演习的孩子兜售稳定未来的承诺呢？精神分析的一大吸引力一直在于它让你剥开层层外壳，盯着世界之下那个巨大的、性感的秘密，
that people were monsters on autopilot that were not in control of the forces that made them run their life? When you're looking at an atomic error and you've just finished a world war, being able to look at the secret horror of humanity had sort of lost its sexiness and its appeal. People wanted a technique, and they also wanted to get rid of the anxiety that they were now feeling, not to dabble in psychological horror
即人们是自动驾驶的怪物，无法控制那些驱动他们生活的力量？当你身处原子时代，刚刚结束一场世界大战时，能够审视人类的秘密恐怖已经失去了它的性感和吸引力。人们想要一种技术，他们也想摆脱他们现在感受到的焦虑，而不是像1920年代的回避时代那样去涉足心理恐怖。德雷珀先生，你听起来很有敌意。花了数百美元，你所做的只是让她更不快乐。我明白这对你来说很令人沮丧。这与我无关。是她。你带走了一个神经衰弱的女人，你让她变得更虚弱，而不是更强大。我只能说这是一个过程，时间是其中的一部分。
as much as they had wanted to in the avoidant era of the 1920s. Mr. Draper, you sound hostile. After hundreds of dollars, all you've managed to do is make her more unhappy. I understand this is frustrating for you. This has nothing to do with me. It's her. You took a woman with a bad case of nerves, and you made her weaker, not stronger. All I can say is that it's a process, and time is part of it.
如果你想加快进度，我们可以让她进行精神分析。你现在在做什么？精神分析心理治疗。精神分析意味着每周至少三次，最好是五次。谢谢。我会考虑的。盛行的心理治疗模型继承了巨大的文化使命，但它们却无法处理自己的阴影。
If you'd like to expedite things, we can put her in psychoanalysis. What are you doing now? Psychoanalytic psychotherapy. Psychoanalysis would mean a minimum of three sessions a week and optimally five. Thank you. I'll think about that. The prevailing models of psychotherapy had inherited a massive cultural mandate, but they were ill-equipped to handle their own shadow.
即使在今天，如果你仔细观察心理学界，它也正遭受着在那个时期发展起来的同样的未解决的身份危机。什么是心理治疗？它是探索人类灵魂不可计算深度的哲学系的一个分支吗？它是对意识或宗教的探索吗？它是制药机构的一个分支，一种调节神经化学的生物机制吗？它是生物医学模型的一个分支，在医院严格的等级制度下运作吗？还是它只是喜欢研究人类的人？我们允许他们在空间中运作，以便希望他们能收集到一些有趣的信息。提供者们自己也不统一。
And even today, if you look closely at the psychological establishment, it is suffering from the same unresolved identity crisis that developed at this time. What is psychotherapy? Is it a branch of the philosophy department exploring the uncomputable depths of the human soul? Is it the search for consciousness or religion? Is it a branch of the pharmaceutical agency, a biological mechanism for adjusting neurochemistry? Is it a branch of the biomedical model, functioning under the rigid hierarchy of the hospital? Or is it just people who like to study humans? that we allow to operate in the space so that hopefully they glean some interesting information. The providers themselves don't agree.
他们不断地在内部争斗，根据自己的观点在沙地上划定意识形态界限。而在所有内斗之下，是一种深刻的、瘫痪的焦虑。因为心理治疗处理的是人类痛苦的主观、不可见领域，它总是感到不安，因为它没有像物理学或外科手术那样严肃的、客观的硬科学合法性。所以每当心理学感到受到威胁时，它就会采用硬科学的美学来保护自己。而在1950年代，它选择的美学就是技术修复的按钮式机器。
They constantly fight among themselves, drawing ideological lines in the sand based on their own perspectives. And beneath all the end fighting is a deep paralyzing insecurity. Because psychotherapy deals with the subjective invisible realm of human suffering, it constantly feels insecure that it doesn't have a serious objective legitimacy of a hard science, like physics or surgery. So whenever psychology feels threatened, it adopts the aesthetics of hard science to be. protect itself. And in the 1950s, the aesthetics it chose was the push-button machinery of the techno fix.
好了，等一下。等一下。我叫医生。呼叫雷西医生。肯·雷西医生。是的，杰森太太。1955年，华莱士实验室发布了一种名为甲丙氨酯的药物，以友好的名字“米尔敦”销售。它成为了美国历史上第一种重磅炸弹式的大众市场精神药物。米尔敦被明确地作为家庭主妇的“和平药丸”进行营销。它作为一种中枢神经抑制剂，本质上是一种能使大脑情绪受体迟钝的肌肉松弛剂。它并没有改变郊区家庭主妇那种压抑的原子化孤立状态，但它确实，
All right, hold on. Just hold on. I'll call the doctor. Calling Dr. Racy. Dr. Ken Racy. Yes, Mrs. Jetson. In 1955, Wallace Laboratory is released a drug called Meprobomate, marketed under the friendly name, Milltown. And it became the first blockbuster mass market psychotropic drug in American history. Miltown was explicitly marketed as a peace pill for homemakers. It functioned as a central nervous depressant, essentially a muscle relaxant that dulled the brain's emotional receptors. And it did not alter the crushing atomized isolation of the suburban housewife, but it did
掩盖了恐慌、恐惧和深刻的结构性绝望。这就是精神药理学行业意识到他们偶然发现了医学史上最大的金矿的地方。高管们意识到，如果他们积极地与军事的“正常”神话结盟，他们就能永远从中获利，因为统计学上的“正常”是一个数学抽象。对于一个真实的人类来说，实现它是功能上不可能的。米尔敦在治疗什么？官方说法是它治疗焦虑，但它所治疗的焦虑往往是缺乏自主权的健康有机体的适当反应，而服用米尔敦的女性并没有坏掉。她们被困住了，而药物并没有解决这个陷阱。它让它变得可以忍受。这种模式在安定身上重复出现，
muffle the panic, the dread, and the profound structural despair. And this is where the psychopharmacology industry realized that they had stumbled upon the greatest gold mine in the history of medicine. The executives realized that if they aggressively allied themselves with the military's myth of normal. They could profit off of it forever because the statistical normal was a mathematical abstraction. It was functionally impossible for a real human being to achieve it. What was Miletown treating? Officially it treated anxiety, but the anxiety it treated was often the appropriate response of healthy organisms without agency, and the women taking Miltown were not broken. They were trapped, and the drug did not fix the trap. It made it tolerable. The pattern would repeat with value,
1963年推出，在滚石乐队的歌曲之后被称为“母亲的小帮手”。安定比米尔敦更成功，到1978年，每年售出23亿片。美国已经变成了一个需要大规模镇静才能运作的国家，而精神病学界在很大程度上接受了这种安排。药物起作用了，在它们减轻症状的意义上。它给了精神病学一个快速简单的解决方案，以证明其作为一种职业的合理性，患者报告感觉更好。他们通常能够继续履行作为家庭主妇、母亲、消费者的角色。症状往往是其他潜在痛苦信号的事实被忽略了。那是来自有机体的警告，表明出了问题，但被系统性地忽略了。
introduced in 1963, which became known as Mother's Little Helper after the Rolling Stone song. Valium was even more successful than Milltown, and by 1978, 2.3 billion tablets were being sold annually. America had become a nation that required mass sedation to function, and the psychiatric establishment largely accepted this arrangement. The medication worked, in the sense that they reduced symptoms. It gave psychiatry a quick and easy fix in order to justify itself as a profession, and patients reported feeling better. They were often able to continue functioning in their roles as housewives, as mothers, as consumers. The facts that the symptoms were often signals of other latent suffering were ignored. There were warnings from the organism that something was wrong and systemically ignored.
因此，当主流生物医学心理学将自己降格为引擎技术员，进行日常维护的月度换油时，边缘地带正在改变当时人类自主权和意识的隐喻，随着加利福尼亚的科学。一个关键时刻发生在几乎没有专业圈子以外的人听说过的一系列会议上，即梅西控制论会议。在1946年到1953年间举行，这些聚会汇集了数学家、工程师、生物学家和社会科学家，讨论一种关于系统的新思维方式：控制论。
And so while mainstream biomedical psychology had consigned itself to the role of engine technician doing monthly oil changes for routine maintenance, the fringes were changing metaphors of what. human agency and consciousness was at this time with the sciences of California. A pivotal moment occurred at a series of conferences that almost nobody outside specialist circles had ever heard of, the Macy conferences on cybernetics. Help between 1946 and 1953, these gatherings brought together mathematicians, engineers, biologists, and social scientists to discuss a new way of thinking about systems, cybernetics.
同样的困难适用于所有数学。如果你能在开始之前准确地定义关系，然后将它们转化为数学符号，数学就会完美地工作。但问题在于选择这些关系并定义它们。尽管如此，如果我们想应对未来，我们就必须理解越来越复杂的系统。
The same difficulty applies to all mathematics. If you could define the relationships exactly before you set out and then translate them into mathematical symbols, the mathematics would work perfectly. But it is in choosing those relationships and defining them that we have the problem. Nevertheless, we are going to have to understand ever more complex systems if we are to deal with the future.
没有它们的理解，可能就没有未来。在节目的早些时候，我们听到了维纳是如何在他试图帮助高射炮手击中敌机时首次发展出他的反馈概念的。在这里，我们有一个模拟击落航天器的电子游戏。让我们玩那个游戏。这个术语是由诺伯特·维纳创造的。控制论是研究动物和机器中控制和通信的学科。它的核心洞察是，生物体和机械装置都可以，
Without their understanding, there may be no future. Earlier in the program, we heard how Vena first developed his feedback concept when he was trying to help anti-aircraft gunners to hit enemy planes. Here, we have a video game which simulates the shooting down of spacecraft. Let's play that game. The term was coined by Norbert Wiener. Cyrenetics was the study of control and communications in animals, machines. Its central insight was that both living organisms and mechanical devices could be
通过相同的概念来理解：反馈回路、信息处理和稳态调节。在同一会议上，克劳德·香农正在展示他的信息数学理论。当香农证明信息可以被量化、以比特为单位测量、通过通道传输时，心灵不再是一台蒸汽机。现在它是一个程序。将在1960年代和1970年代改变心理学的认知革命建立在控制论的基础上。思想变成了程序，记忆变成了存储在生物硬件中的数据。精神疾病变成了软件中的漏洞。当你把心灵想象成一台计算机时，某些问题变得自然，而另一些则变得不可见。
understood through the same concepts, feedback loops, information processing, and homeostatic regulation. At the same conferences, Claude Shannon was presenting his mathematical theory of information. When Shannon showed that information could be quantified, measured in bits, transmitted through channels, the mind was no longer a steam engine. Now it was a program. The cognitive revolution that would transform psychology in the 1960s and 1970s was built on cybernetic foundations. Thoughts became programs, and memories became data stored in biological hardware. Mental illness became bugs in the software. And when you think of the mind as a computer, certain questions become natural and others become invisible.
你询问处理速度。你不会询问意义、目的或作为意识存在的生命体验。这些问题无法计算。控制论革命强化了美国心理学的个人主义倾向。计算机不存在于关系中。它没有社区。它只需要正确运作。如果精神疾病是软件漏洞，那么治疗就是调试，而治疗关系就变得无关紧要了。重要的是技术。当时资金最充足的意识形态流派是数学家、经济学家和战略家，
You ask about processing speed. You don't ask about meaning, purpose, or the lived experience of being conscious. Those questions don't compute. The cybernetic revolution reinforced the individual. tendency of American psychology. A computer does not exist in relationship. It does not have a community. It needs only to function correctly. And if mental illness is a software bug, then treatment is debugging, and the therapeutic relationship becomes irrelevant. What matters is the technique. The most heavily funded ideological currents of the time were mathematicians, economists, and strategists
他们主要通过兰德公司聚集在一起，由美国国防部和空军资助，去思考不可想象的事情：核战争。这些智库开发的答案是博弈论，一种分析战略互动的数学框架。博弈论将人类视为理性行为者，他们计算成本和收益，并选择策略来增加奖励和减少惩罚。在兰德公司内部存在着深刻的意识形态分歧，
that had been brought together largely through the RAND Corporation, funded by the US DOD and the Air Force, to think about the unthinkable, nuclear war. The answer that these think tanks developed was game theory, a mathematical framework for analyzing strategic interaction. Game theory treated human beings as rational actors, who calculated costs and benefits and chose strategies to increase reward and decrease punishment. A profound internal ideological division existed at the brand
关于战争的心理学。数学分析部门（MAD）严重依赖技术战略语言，一种经过消毒的超理性词汇，蓄意剥离了核毁灭概念中的情感和道德重量。在这些定量战争游戏模拟中，玩家被简化为模拟计算机的逻辑，经常毫不犹豫地升级核发射。相比之下，社会科学部门（SSD）设计了具有高度叙事真实性的游戏，调动了情感智能，导致了显著的核克制。这很早就证明了语言的刻意抽象有效地覆盖了人类对抗大规模暴力的障碍。
regarding the psychology of warfare. The mathematics analytics division, Mad, relied heavily on the technostratic language. a sanitized hyper-rational vocabulary that deliberately stripped the emotional and moral weight from the concept of nuclear annihilation. In these quantitative war game simulations, players were reduced to the logic of an analog computer, frequently escalating nuclear launches without hesitation. In stark contrast, the Social Sciences Division, or SSD, designed games with high narrative realism, engaging emotional intelligence, resulting in marked nuclear restraint. And this proved early on that deliberate abstraction of language effectively overrides human barriers against mass violence.
但随着时间的推移，影响心理学和大型机构的同样的焦虑——在危机时期或机构不安全或不确定时期转向硬科学——影响了国防部。数学模型开始塑造它所描述的现实。如果你设计机构时假设人们是战略计算者，你就会创造激励。你创造了奖励战略计算的激励。最终，人们学会了把自己视为战略计算者。关于隐喻的战争结束了。
But over time, the same insecurity that affects psychology and large institutions, the pivot towards hard sciences in times of crisis or in times of institutional insecurity or uncertainty, affected the DoD. The mathematical model began to shape the reality that it described. If you design institutions assuming that people are strategic calculators, you create incentives. you create incentives that reward strategic calculation. And eventually, people learn to think of themselves as strategic calculators. The war for the metaphor was over.
1964年，一位名叫埃里克·伯恩的精神科医生出版了一本书，将博弈论思维引入了美国中产阶级。《人们玩的游戏》是我们在这个播客之前的一个系列中谈到过的一本书。这是一本流行心理学书籍，充满了伯恩在他患者和关系中观察到的模式的朗朗上口的名称。伯恩将游戏定义为一种具有隐藏心理回报的重复性互动模式。这本书有效地将来自国防部的博弈论与精神分析的语言融合在一起，并且非常符合时代精神。在有机社区被竞争性消费所取代的郊区，
And in 1964, a psychiatrist named Eric Byrne published a book that would introduce game theoretic thinking to the American middle class. The Games People Play is a book we've talked about on an earlier series that this podcast put out. It was a popular psychology book filled with catchy names for the patterns that Byrne had observed in his patients and relationships. Burn defined a game as a reoccurring pattern of interaction with a hidden psychological payoff. The book effectively effused game theory coming out of the DoD with the language of psychoanalysis, and it fit the zeitgeist perfectly. In the suburbs where organic community had been replaced by competitive consumption,
关系确实感觉像游戏。交易分析取得了巨大的成功。随着心灵的控制论观点与这种战略的博弈论观点相结合，一位名叫欧文·戈夫曼的社会学家捕捉到了战后时代的精确心理机制。在他的书《日常生活中的自我呈现》中，戈夫曼认为人类本质上是舞台上的演员。我们不断地进行印象管理。有一个前台，我们在那里表演幸福的郊区生活、完美的婚姻、成功的职业生涯，还有一个后台，我们在那里摘下面具，被表演弄得精疲力竭。
relationships really did feel like games. Transactual and analysis was a meteoric hit. As the cybernetic view of the mind combined with this game theoretic view of strategy, A sociologist named Irvin Goffman captured the exact psychological mechanism of the post-war era. In his book, The Presentation of Self in Everyday Life, Goffman argued that human beings are essentially actors on a stage. We are constantly engaged in impression management. There is a front stage where we perform the happy suburban life, the perfect marriage, the successful career, and there is the backstage where we drop the mask, exhausted by the performance.
戈夫曼的理论暗示根本没有真正的真实自我，只有一系列为了在空洞的社会中航行而戴上的计算面具。当你把心灵作为计算机的控制论观点与戈夫曼将自我作为表演者的社会学观点结合起来时，你就得到了一个由孤立节点组成的社会，疯狂地管理着他们的形象以在郊区生存。理解这种表演机器至关重要，因为它解释了婴儿潮一代的心理。婴儿潮一代拒绝向下看。
In Gothman's theory implied that there was no true authentic self at all. just a series of calculated masks worn to navigate a hollow society. And when you combine the cybernetic view of the mind as a computer with the Goffman's sociological view of the self as a performer, you get a society of isolated notes, frantically managing their image to survive in the suburbs. And this performative machine is vitally important to understand, because it explains the psychology of the baby boomers. The boomers refused to look down.
他们拒绝质疑某些他们知道在幕后运作的结构性真相。在内心深处，他们知道这些郊区本质上是像西部电影布景一样建造的，好莱坞的门面在假装永恒。他们知道社区是一个幻觉，但承认布景是假的将需要放弃表演的安全性。这正是为什么他们的孩子后来（你知道，X世代和千禧一代）会如此剧烈地（尽管最终不成功地）做出反应，去选择另一个可以推动文化向另一个方向发展的愿景。他们能看到西部小镇门面上的裂缝，
They refuse to question certain structural truths that they knew were operating behind. the scenes deep down and they knew that these suburbs were essentially built like Western movie sets Hollywood facades playing at permanence they knew that the community was an illusion but to admit that the set was fake would require abandoning the safety of the performance and this is exactly why their children would later you know Generation X and Millennials react so violently through ultimately unsuccessfully to picking another vision that could pull the culture in another direction they could see the cracks in the Western town facades
而他们的父母已经同意礼貌地忽略它们。亚当·斯密需要修订。你在说什么？如果我们都去追那个金发女郎，我们就会互相阻碍。我们中没有一个人能得到她。所以我们就去追她的朋友。但她们都会给我们冷脸，因为没人喜欢做第二选择。
and their parents had agreed to politely ignore them. Adam Smith needs revision. What are you talking about? If we all go for the blonde, we block each other. Not a single one of us is going to get her. So then we go for her friends. But they will all give us the cold shoulder because nobody likes to be second choice.
如果没人去追那个金发女郎呢？我们不会互相阻碍。我们也不会侮辱其他女孩。那是我们获胜的唯一途径。那是我们都能成功的唯一途径。亚当·斯密说最好的结果来自群体中的每个人都做对他自己最有利的事，对吧？他是这么说的，对吗？
What if no one goes for the blonde? We don't get in each other's way. And we don't insult the other girls. That's the only way we win. That's the only way we all get late. Adam Smith said the best result comes from everyone in the group doing what's best for himself, right? That's what he said, is that right?
不完整，不完整。好吧？因为最好的结果来自群体中的每个人都做对他自己和群体最有利的事。阿什，这是你独自得到金发女郎的一种方式。你可以下地狱去。治理动态，先生们。
Incomplete, incomplete. Okay? Because the best result would come from everyone in the group doing what's best for himself and the group. Ash, this is some way for you to get the blonde on your own. You can go to hell. Governing and down average, gentlemen.
治理动态。亚当·斯密。人类潜能运动的出现是对这种新的人类观念冷漠危机的回应。它的中心是1962年在加利福尼亚州大苏尔壮观的悬崖上成立的伊萨兰研究所。伊萨兰不是单一的东西。它是一个许多不同方法汇聚、碰撞和交叉授粉的空间。像亚伯拉罕·马斯洛这样的人本主义心理学家带来了他们的自我实现理论。弗里茨·皮尔斯带来了格式塔疗法，
Governing dynamics. Adam Smith. The human potential movement emerged as a response to the crisis of the coldness of this new conception of humanity. At its epicenter was the Eastland Institute founded in 1962 on the spectacular cliffs of Big Sur, California. Eastland was not a single thing. It was a space where many different approaches converged, collided, and cross-pollinated. Humanistic psychologists like Abraham Maslow brought their theories of self-actualization. Fritz Perils brought Gestral- Therapy. with its emphasis on present moment awareness, emotional expression,
强调当下意识、情感表达，以及其体验性质，后来与荣格的理论融合，创造了像内部家庭系统这样的基于部分的疗法。亚历山大·洛温带来了生物能量分析，一种源自威廉·赖希的身体导向方法。艾伦·沃茨带来了禅宗佛教和东方哲学，艾达·罗尔夫带来了结构整合，通过操纵身体的结缔组织来释放慢性紧张。我想买给世界一个家，并用爱来装饰它。
and its experiential nature that would later be fused with Jung's theories to create parts-based therapies like internal family systems. Alexander Lowen brought bio-energetic analysis, a body-based approach descended from Wilhelm Reich. Alan Watts brought Zen Buddhism and Eastern philosophy, and Ida Rolf brought structural integration, manipulating the body's connective tissue to release chronic tension. I'd like to buy the world a home and furnish it with love.
种上苹果树和蜜蜂，还有白色的斑鸠。我想教世界和我一起歌唱。这些方法共同点是拒绝主流心理学范式。他们拒绝弗洛伊德对病理学、挖掘童年创伤、将分析师视为权威人物的强调，他们拒绝行为主义对内在体验的否定，他们拒绝将心理困扰视为一种需要消除的疾病而不是需要理解的信号的医学模型，
Grow apple trees and honeybees and so white turtle does. I like to teach the world to sing with me. What these approaches shared was a rejection of the dominant psychological paradigm. They rejected the Freudian emphasis on pathology, on uncovering childhood trauma, on the analysts as an authority figure, and they rejected the behavioralist denier of inner experience, and they rejected the medical model that treated psychological distress as a disease to be eliminated rather than a signal to be understood,
他们拒绝将人视为计算机的控制论心灵观，认为输入和输出就是他们的一切。相反，他们提出人类拥有巨大的、未开发的成长、创造力和超越潜力，可以引领我们进入下一个时代。然后这与新时代运动对水瓶座和进入新意识时代的痴迷重叠了。交叉授粉非常极端。心理工作的目标不是适应社会，
and they rejected a cyber genetic vision of the mind as a person as a computer, with inputs and outputs that was all that they are. Instead, they proposed that human beings have vast untapped potential for growth, creativity and transcendence that could lead us into the next era. Then this overlapped with the New Age movement's obsession with Aquarius and moving into a new age of consciousness. And the cross-pollination was pretty extreme. The goal of psychological work was not adjusting to society,
而是自我实现，成为更完整的自己，更有能力。身体不是心灵的不便容器，而是智慧的源泉，是能量阻塞的场所，可以被释放。东方精神实践提供了西方心理学所忽略的意识技术。这在许多方面是对威廉·詹姆斯几十年前提出的建议的恢复，也是对卡尔·荣格等精神分析学家的回归。这是对意识流、激进经验主义的回归，并坚持主观体验很重要，超越的生活是真实的，内在生活是真实的，可测量的并不是唯一的衡量方式。
but self-actualization, becoming more fully who you were and more capable of being. The body was not an inconvenient container for the mind, but a source of wisdom, a locus of blocked energy that could be released. and Eastern spiritual practices offered technologies of consciousness that Western psychology had ignored. This was in many ways a recovery of what William James had proposed decades earlier, and a return to psychoanalysts like Carl Jung. It was a return to the stream of consciousness, to radical empiricism, and to the insistence that the subjective experience mattered, that the transcendent life was real, that the inner life was real, and that the measurable was not the only way to measure.
遭遇小组成为该运动的标志性实践。在电视剧《广告狂人》的最后一集中，强烈暗示唐在伊萨兰参加一个遭遇小组，如果你看过那部剧的话。在遭遇小组中，参与者聚集在一起练习激进的诚实，公开表达他们的感受并接受他人的反馈。正常的社交互动规则被暂停了。你被鼓励说出你真实的感受，
The encounter group became the signature practice of the movement. The final episode of the show Mad Men, it's heavily implied that Don is at an encounter group in Eastland, if you've seen that show. And an encounter group participants gathered to practice radical honesty, expressing their feelings openly and receiving feedback from others. And the rules of normal social interaction were suspended. You were encouraged to say what you actually felt,
即使当它很丑陋时，即使它违反了礼貌。真实性被置于表演之上。对于许多参与者来说，这些经历确实是变革性的。他们报告了在普通生活或传统治疗中从未经历过的连接、突破、宣泄的时刻。那些房间里发生的事情是真实的，但它无法被测量，既不是作为行动机制，也不是作为治疗结果。那是一种超越数字的、不言自明的真理。但我们必须澄清一个常见的误解。人类潜能运动和控制论并非完全对立。
even when it was ugly, even if it violated politely. authenticity was prized over performance. And for many participants, these experiences were genuinely transformative. They reported moments of connection, breakthrough, catharsis, that they had never experienced in ordinary life or in conventional therapy. And something was real that was happening in those rooms, but it couldn't be measured, not as a mechanism of action, and also not as a result of therapy. It was something that was a truth that was self-evident, beyond the numbers. But we must clear a common misunderstanding. The human potential movement and cybernetics were not entirely opposed.
实际上，它们是紧密交织的。它们都是知识分子和思想家视为他们时代发现前沿的两大主流。早期的技术先驱和控制论者是伊萨兰的常客，而将控制论转化为个人解放工具的工作在很大程度上是由斯图尔特·布兰德通过创建《全球概览》来促成的。在精英工程团队附近运作，布兰德和他的合作者将小规模技术和信息网络视为破坏官僚机构和赋予个人权力的机制。《全球概览》充当了反文化技术的圣经。像格雷戈里·贝特森这样的人类学家和控制论者深刻影响了布兰德和伊萨兰。他们认为，
In reality, they were deeply entwined. They were both major currents that intellectuals and thinkers saw as the forefront of the discoveries of their era. Early tech pioneers and cyberneticists were frequent visitors at Eekyllen, and the translation of cybernetics into a tool for personal liberation was largely brokered by Stuart Brand, though through the creation of the whole earth catalog. Operating near elite engineering teams, Brand and his collaborators viewed small-scale technologies and information networks as mechanisms to undermine bureaucracies and empower the individual. The whole Earth catalog functioned as a Bible of counterculture technology. Anthropologists and cyberneticians like Gregory Bateson deeply influenced both Brand and Eastland. They argue that the
心灵和环境是一个单一的共同进化信息系统的一部分。结果，反文化寻找自我的追求与优化自我的工程必要性变得密不可分。计算机隐喻不仅仅是被军方强加给我们的。我们在寻找解放的过程中拥抱了它。最终，内心世界变成了一种产品，一种可以影响外部物质世界的东西，不仅仅是主观体验的内省点，而是一种如果你帮助自己就能帮助他人帮助他人的东西。人类潜能运动的真正力量是因为其中运作的一些角色。有些人真正误解了心理学，有些人从根本上误解了，
mind and the environment were part of a single co-evolving information system. As a result, the countercultural quest to find oneself became inextricably linked to the engineering imperative to optimize oneself. The computer metaphor wasn't just forced on us by the military. We embraced it in our search for liberation. Finally, the inner world had become a product and something that could affect the outer material world, not just a naval gazing inner point of subjective experience, but something that could help you help others if you helped yourself. The true power of the human petitional movement was because of some of the characters operating in it. There were people who genuinely misunderstood psychology and people who fundamentally misunderstood
美国是如何运作的。这场运动变成了相互竞争的原型的混乱碰撞。有企业骗子，你知道，像早期NLP中涉及的一些人，他们吸食了大量可卡因，并包装心理洞察的碎片，因为他们的聪明才智，以便将它们武器化成他们可以迅速卖给企业的东西。这些人中有些是自恋者，他们真诚地认为自己是上帝，而其他人只是不在乎你是否把他们误认为是上帝。其次，有这些天真的理想主义者。这些是善意的治疗师，他们相信如果美国发明了一种充满爱、关怀、完美的心理学，受创伤的群众就会排队乞求被治愈。
how America works. The movement became a chaotic collision of competing archetypes. There were corporate grifters, you know, figures like some of the people involved in early NLP, who were very high on cocaine and packaging fragments of psychological insight due to their, you know, intelligence in order to weaponize them into something that they could sell quickly to a corporation. Some of these people were narcissists who genuinely thought that they were God and others simply just didn't care if you mistook them for him. And second, there were these naive idealists. And these were the well-meaning therapist who believed that if America simply invented a kumbaya loving, caring, perfect psychology, the traumatized masses would line up begging to be cured.
美国是如何运作的。这场运动演变成了一场相互竞争的原型之间的混乱碰撞。其中有企业骗子，你知道的，比如一些参与早期神经语言程序学（NLP）的人，他们吸食了大量可卡因，并将心理学洞察的碎片进行包装，利用他们的聪明才智，将其武器化，变成可以迅速卖给企业的东西。这些人中，有些是自恋者，他们真心认为自己就是上帝，而另一些人则根本不在乎你是否把他们误认为是上帝。其次，还有那些天真的理想主义者。他们是那些好心的治疗师，他们相信如果美国能发明一种充满爱与关怀、让人和谐共处的完美心理学，那些受过创伤的民众就会排着队恳求被治愈。
And this was a profound misunderstanding of the American psyche, which is always valued rugged individualism and productivity over vulnerability. They thought that love alone could dismantle this military industrial complex and that eventually if you ordered organic seeds and meditated, things in the exterior world were changed. There was also a lot of New Age Hocum. This was this friend that believed in laylines and magic crystals would one day supplant the microchip through the inevitability of magic being better than science. Con artists who spoke the language of the New Age movement and cybernetics in order to scam people, like the Beatles, the Magic Alex guy that sold them the like
这深刻地误解了美国人的心理，因为美国人向来推崇坚韧的个人主义和生产力，而非脆弱感。他们认为仅凭爱就能瓦解这个军工复合体，认为只要订购有机种子并进行冥想，外部世界就会发生改变。当时还有很多新时代的胡言乱语。有位朋友相信地脉和魔法水晶，认为魔法终将取代微芯片，因为魔法必然优于科学。还有些骗子利用新时代运动和控制论的术语来诈骗，比如披头士乐队遇到的那个“魔法亚历克斯”，他卖给他们……
10,000 million point one surround sound studio or whatever. You know, these pioneers in trauma and semantic psychology were doing incredible work. They were finally beginning to understand how trauma lives in the nervous system in the midst of all of these waters with some of the better therapy that the country had ever done. You know, they were learning how the body held attention. And they were seeing how when you put all of these different fields
一千万点一环绕声工作室之类的东西。要知道，这些创伤和语义心理学的先驱们当时正在进行令人难以置信的工作。在这些混乱的思潮中，他们终于开始理解创伤是如何存在于神经系统中的，并运用了当时国内一些最好的疗法。他们正在学习身体是如何承载注意力的。他们也看到了，当你把所有这些不同的领域……
that were getting at something real but hard to measure in the same spot, big Venn diagrams and overlaps came. Many of the new models of psychotherapy, the third and fourth wave models, have roots in this era, and would have been inevitable without this fusion in Eastland. Therapists like Peter Levin were sort of a successor to people like Wilhelm Reich, based on a couple levels of influence in between them. But because of the noise, it's crucial to understand that the human potential movement
放在一起时——这些领域虽然触及了真实的东西，却难以衡量——就会出现巨大的维恩图和重叠部分。许多新的心理治疗模型，即第三和第四波模型，都植根于那个时代，如果没有伊萨兰（Esalen）的这种融合，它们本不会出现。像彼得·莱文（Peter Levine）这样的治疗师，在某种程度上是威廉·赖希（Wilhelm Reich）等人的继任者，尽管他们之间隔着几层影响。但由于噪音太大，理解“人类潜能运动”至关重要……
and the broader counterculture of which it was a part did not really end in a counterculture. It was a counter aesthetic. The distinction is important here because a counterculture could have challenged the fundamental structures that were producing the void that America was feeling. The economic arrangements,
以及它所属的更广泛的反主流文化，其实并没有真正终结于反主流文化。它是一种“反审美”。这里的区别很重要，因为反主流文化本可以挑战那些制造美国人内心空虚的根本结构。比如经济安排、
the spatial organization, the institutional incentives that atomized individuals and reduced relationships to transactions. A counterculture would have built alternative institutions created different ways of organizing, creating family and community,
空间组织，以及那些将个人原子化并将人际关系简化为交易的制度激励。反主流文化本可以建立替代性机构，创造不同的组织方式，建立家庭和社区，
and established, you know, enduring structures that embodied different values. That didn't happen. What actually emerged was a counter-aesthetic, a set of styles, attitudes, taste, and practices that provided the feeling of opposition without threatening the underlying structure. And you could grow your hair long, you could wear different clothes, you could listen to different music, you could take different drugs, practice spiritual techniques, and still fully participate in a consumer economy. And the people running the consumer economy noticed that. They started to sell the counterculture to itself, and the counterculture is a product to other people. who felt the guilt of not participating in the movement, but really didn't want to change. The sociologist Sam Binkley, in his study of the 1970s, Getting Loose, traced how this transformation occurred. The ethos of getting loose, of releasing the body from its discipline constraints, of breaking free from the uptight conformity of the 50s, was genuinely appealing to millions of Americans. It spoke to real needs, real deprivations, and a real.
并建立起体现不同价值观的持久结构。但这并没有发生。实际上出现的是一种“反审美”，即一套风格、态度、品味和实践，它们提供了反抗的感觉，却并没有威胁到潜在的结构。你可以留长发，穿不同的衣服，听不同的音乐，吸不同的毒品，练习精神技巧，同时仍然完全参与消费经济。而经营消费经济的人注意到了这一点。他们开始向反主流文化群体兜售反主流文化本身，并将反主流文化作为一种产品卖给其他人——那些因为没有参与运动而感到内疚，但实际上并不想改变的人。社会学家萨姆·宾克利（Sam Binkley）在他关于20世纪70年代的研究《Getting Loose》中，追踪了这种转变是如何发生的。“Getting Loose”（放飞自我）的理念，即从纪律约束中释放身体，从50年代紧张的循规蹈矩中解脱出来，对数百万美国人来说确实很有吸引力。它回应了真实的需求、真实的匮乏，以及一种真实的……
real hunger for authentic experience. But getting loose was systematically stripped of its radical potential and repackaged as a lifestyle choice. The techniques that were supposed to liberate the self became commodities. Yoga was a fitness class. Meditation was a stress management technique. Encounter groups became the corporate team building exercises, and hundreds of corporate team building coaches came out of Eastland. This wasn't a conspiracy. It was the ordinary operation of market forces on cultural material. The youth invents the culture. to scandalize the older people. And then it becomes the dominant culture,
对真实体验的渴望。但“放飞自我”被系统性地剥离了其激进的潜力，并被重新包装成一种生活方式的选择。那些本应解放自我的技巧变成了商品。瑜伽变成了健身课。冥想变成了压力管理技巧。遭遇小组（Encounter groups）变成了企业团队建设练习，而数百名企业团队建设教练正是从伊萨兰走出来的。这不是阴谋，而是市场力量对文化材料的常规运作。年轻人发明文化来让长辈感到震惊，然后它就变成了主流文化，
and they buy flattering imitations of their own lifestyle and rebellion. The culture industries are extraordinarily efficient at absorbing opposition, stripping of political content, and selling it back to the public at style. The fundamental structures remained untouched. The suburbs still isolated people,
于是他们购买对自己生活方式和反叛行为的奉承式模仿。文化产业在吸收反抗、剥离其政治内容并将其作为一种风格卖回给公众方面效率极高。根本结构依然未受触动。郊区依然孤立着人们，
the corporation still demanded conformity, and the economy still required endless consumption. But now you could buy a weekend workshop where you screamed and cried and did primal scream therapy to hug strangers, and then return on Monday to the same job, the same home, and the same fundamental arrangements. The void wasn't filled, it was decorated. And throughout all these transformations, actual therapy was happening. People were sitting in rooms with other people, trying to understand their suffering, trying to find paths forward.
公司依然要求服从，经济依然需要无休止的消费。但现在你可以买一个周末工作坊，在那里尖叫、哭泣、进行原始尖叫疗法、拥抱陌生人，然后周一回到同样的工作、同样的家和同样的根本安排中。空虚没有被填补，只是被装饰了一番。在所有这些转变中，真正的治疗确实在发生。人们坐在房间里，与他人在一起，试图理解自己的痛苦，试图寻找前进的道路。
So what did therapy look like? By the 1970s, the therapeutic landscape had become remarkably diverse. Psychodynamic therapy remained influential, that evolution of Freud based on people who were using attachment theory instead of sex. And though it evolved considerably from what Freud was doing, you know, do works of people like Heinz Cohut and Karen Hornay. You know, Cohut's self-psychology emphasized empathy, the need for self-object relationship that provided mirroring and validation.
那么治疗是什么样的呢？到了20世纪70年代，治疗领域变得非常多样化。心理动力学疗法依然具有影响力，那是弗洛伊德理论的演变，基于那些使用依恋理论而非性理论的人。虽然它与弗洛伊德的做法相比有了很大演变，比如海因茨·科胡特（Heinz Kohut）和卡伦·霍妮（Karen Horney）的作品。科胡特的自体心理学强调共情，强调对自体客体关系的需求，这种关系提供镜像和确认。
And it was warmer and more relational in psychoanalysis. Object relations theory developed by figures in Britain like Melanie Klein and Donald Winnicott or Ronald Fairbain shaping American practice. And these theorists emphasized the internalized representations of early relationships and how these internal objects shape our experience of current relationships. Gestralt therapy is developed by Fritz Perils and refined by subsequent practitioners, offered genuine tools for working with awareness, with the body, and with unfinished emotional business. It emphasized a present moment experience of taking responsibility for one's choices,
它比精神分析更温暖、更具关系性。由英国的梅兰妮·克莱因（Melanie Klein）、唐纳德·温尼科特（Donald Winnicott）或罗纳德·费尔贝恩（Ronald Fairbairn）等人物发展的客体关系理论塑造了美国的实践。这些理论家强调早期关系的内化表征，以及这些内部客体如何塑造我们对当前关系的体验。由弗里茨·皮尔斯（Fritz Perls）开发并由后续从业者完善的格式塔疗法，为处理意识、身体和未完成的情感事务提供了真正的工具。它强调当下体验，强调为自己的选择负责，
completing interrupted cycles of action and feeling. And these were not merely fashionable ideas, they were clinical insights that were really helping people. And the family systems approach matured into multiple schools. Therapists like Murray Bowen, Virginia Seteer, and Salvador Mnuchin, recognized that individuals exist inrelationalable systems, began to use the language of cybernetics to understand emotions as a system. They began to depathologize symptoms,
完成中断的行动和情感循环。这些不仅仅是时髦的想法，它们是真正帮助人们的临床见解。家庭系统方法也成熟为多个流派。像默里·鲍文（Murray Bowen）、弗吉尼亚·萨提亚（Virginia Satir）和萨尔瓦多·米纽钦（Salvador Minuchin）这样的治疗师认识到，个人存在于关系系统中，开始使用控制论的语言将情绪理解为一个系统。他们开始对症状进行“去病理化”，
seeing them as messages and indicators about the state of the family and what the real problems were. And this depathologized problems in the individual. And these were real contributions. They would influence millions of patients and thousands of therapists, but they remained marginal to the mainstream. And the institutions that trained therapists, the insurance companies that paid for treatment and the academic departments that granted credentials, these remained committed to paradigms that were easier to standardize, easier to measure, and easier to fit into the bureaucratic machinery of American health care. And more importantly, they were systems that could be taught to anyone,
将其视为关于家庭状态和真正问题的信号与指标。这消除了个人身上的病理化问题。这些都是真正的贡献。它们影响了数百万患者和数千名治疗师，但它们在主流中仍然处于边缘地位。而培训治疗师的机构、支付治疗费用的保险公司以及授予资格的学术部门，依然致力于那些更容易标准化、更容易衡量、更容易融入美国医疗官僚机器的范式。更重要的是，这些系统可以教给任何人，
not just a select group of people that might have capacity to view life or hold space in a certain way, because they were models that had if this, then that outputs. It didn't require self-work or emotional maturity in vast quantities on the part of the practitioner. After Vietnam, the American myth was changing. The war didn't just break the narrative of American exceptionalism, but it unleashed a massive unprecedented epidemic of trauma, schizophrenia, and drug addiction among returning veterans who found a society that completely refused to look at them. The map became split between two groups of aesthetics, people who defended the American Dream as exceptional and accurate, and then people who criticized the American Dream as flawed without offering any other sort of solution.
而不仅仅是一小群可能以某种方式看待生活或保持空间的人，因为这些模型具有“如果这样，就那样”的输出。它不需要从业者具备大量的自我工作或情感成熟度。越战后，美国神话正在改变。战争不仅打破了美国例外论的叙事，还在归来的退伍军人中引发了大规模、前所未有的创伤、精神分裂症和药物成瘾流行病，他们发现社会完全拒绝正视他们。地图分裂为两类审美：一类是捍卫美国梦作为例外且准确的人，另一类是批评美国梦有缺陷却不提供任何其他解决方案的人。
And this trauma epidemic, as people began to be aware of PTSD, began to be aware of, began to be aware of schizophrenia, began to be aware of the effects of drug abuse, as they saw it on the streets, collided with another massive structural failure, mass de-institutionalization. Under the guise of progressive reform and cost-cutting, the state began emptying the psychiatric hospitals, and this wasn't entirely a bad thing. People were being held against their will that easily could have lived alone because the society or the system or the family that had put them in the institution didn't want them there. The institution had too much power. People with severe mental illness were often incarcerated in horrific and abusive institutions,
这场创伤流行病——随着人们开始意识到创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）、精神分裂症以及药物滥用的影响，正如他们在街头所见——与另一个巨大的结构性失败发生了碰撞：大规模去机构化。打着进步改革和削减成本的幌子，国家开始清空精神病院，这并不完全是一件坏事。人们被违背意愿地关押，而他们本可以独自生活，因为将他们送进机构的社会、系统或家庭并不想要他们。机构权力过大。患有严重精神疾病的人经常被监禁在可怕且虐待性的机构中，
and reform was needed, and the tragedy is that there were viable alternatives. Models like the assertive community treatment teams existed and had been proven effective. And the act model envisioned a system where a multidisciplinary team of social workers, nurses, and psychiatrists met the patient where they were, inside the community, providing a web of care that functioned as a counterweight to the government. It was administered by healers, not by a police officer or a bureaucratic, But America didn't choose the act model. It didn't fund the community clinic long after the 80s. And the dark, unforgivable truth of the last 60 years of psychiatric reform is that we didn't
改革是必要的，悲剧在于当时存在可行的替代方案。像“主动社区治疗”（ACT）团队这样的模型已经存在并被证明是有效的。ACT模型设想了一个系统，由社会工作者、护士和精神科医生组成的多学科团队在社区内与患者会面，提供一张作为政府制衡力量的护理网。它由治疗师管理，而不是由警察或官僚管理。但美国没有选择ACT模型。它在80年代后并没有长期资助社区诊所。过去60年精神病学改革中黑暗且不可原谅的事实是，我们并没有……
actually cure the asylum. We just took the roof off and we decided to turn the entire section of major major American cities into what are essentially open-air asylums. The untreated, traumatized veterans and the addicted were left to wander the streets, managed only by the penal system and the brutal apathy of the market. And this is ultimately, this, terrifying shadow of American psychology that begins about this time, a system that optimizes the worried well in suburbs while it's structurally abandoning the broken to the concrete. Marshall McLuhan called television a cool medium, by which he meant something intuitive, not that it was emotionally distant, but it required participation to complete.
真正治愈精神病院。我们只是掀掉了屋顶，决定把美国大城市的一整片区域变成本质上的露天精神病院。未经治疗的、受创伤的退伍军人和成瘾者被遗弃在街头流浪，仅由刑罚系统和市场的残酷冷漠来管理。这最终是美国心理学在这个时期开始出现的恐怖阴影：一个在郊区优化“忧虑的富人”，同时在结构上将破碎的人遗弃在水泥地上的系统。马歇尔·麦克卢汉（Marshall McLuhan）称电视为“冷媒介”，他的意思是某种直觉性的东西，并不是说它在情感上疏远，而是它需要参与才能完成。
Unlike the hot medium of film, which provided high-definition images that overwhelmed the viewer, television's low-resolution picture demanded that the viewer's nervous system fill in the missing information. Watching television was participatory. It was not passive in the way that watching a movie was passive. Portland, straight ahead. If you want some friendly advice, a haircut and take a bat, you wouldn't get hassled so much.
与电影这种“热媒介”不同——电影提供高清图像，让观众应接不暇——电视的低分辨率画面要求观众的神经系统去填补缺失的信息。看电视是参与性的。它不像看电影那样是被动的。波特兰，直走。如果你想要点友好的建议，去理个发，洗个澡，你就不会被骚扰得那么厉害了。
Hope this ride helped you out. You have a nice day, huh? Because the new American dream of the suburbs was failing to provide many Americans with a larger sense of meaning, the nation had to find its psychological cohesion elsewhere. It founded in paranoia. America found numerous existential threats and identitarian projects, both internally and outside of the country. Soviets, the bomb, and communism, but also a hippie movement that was failing to integrate and rapidly succumbing to trauma and drugs, especially with the wave of returning.
希望这次搭车对你有帮助。祝你今天愉快，嗯？因为郊区的新美国梦未能为许多美国人提供更宏大的意义感，国家必须在别处寻找心理凝聚力。它在偏执中找到了它。美国发现了无数的存在主义威胁和身份认同项目，无论是在国内还是国外。苏联、原子弹和共产主义，还有未能融入社会并迅速屈服于创伤和毒品的嬉皮士运动，尤其是随着归来的……
Vietnam veterans with PTSD. News was reinventing the apocalypse every 10 years because the system demanded a perpetual state of emergency to justify its economic architecture. And the culture became addicted to that threat, both materially and existentially, because without the threat, it would have to look inward. It wasn't just the hippies that became reactionaries. In the hot tubs of Eastland, as the 1970s bled into the 1980s, the authentic self mutated into the Silicon Valley Randian hero.
患有PTSD的越战老兵。新闻每10年就会重塑一次世界末日，因为系统需要一种永久的紧急状态来证明其经济架构的合理性。文化对这种威胁产生了物质上和存在主义上的双重依赖，因为如果没有威胁，它就必须向内审视。不仅仅是嬉皮士变成了反动派。在伊萨兰的浴缸里，随着70年代步入80年代，真实的自我变异成了硅谷的兰德式英雄。
the techno-libertarian Ein-Rand protagonist who believed that society itself was obsolete, that we should bulldoze all of the restraints that society placed on the individual to make room for the rise of Randian Ubermensch heroes. The 1950s and 60s had seen the resurrection of the cowboy as the American hero. But by the 1970s and 80s, the American hero myth began to mutate into the ruthless businessman. The evolution of television and its role in American life had profound implications for American consciousness. Television watching created a particular neurological state. Alert but not active, engaged but not thinking, present but not reflecting. The viewer was absorbed into the image
那个相信社会本身已经过时、我们应该推倒社会强加给个人的所有束缚，为兰德式超人英雄的崛起腾出空间的科技自由意志主义者。50和60年代见证了牛仔作为美国英雄的复活。但到了70和80年代，美国英雄神话开始变异为冷酷的商人。电视的演变及其在美国生活中的角色对美国意识产生了深远影响。看电视创造了一种特定的神经状态。警觉但不活跃，投入但不思考，在场但不反思。观众被吸入图像中……
through pathos, not observing it from distance. The critical faculties required by print, the ability to stop, reread, question, compare, were suspended. Screen became what Theodore Adorno would call the ultimate tool of the culture industry, a mechanism of mass deception where standardized cultural goods replaced authentic science. psychological reflection. And the televised image stripped of its authentic presence, what Walter Benjamin termed aura, trained the viewer in a state of distracted reception. Three networks dominated American television from the 1940s through the 70s, accomplishing what, something that had never been done before, a unified field of consciousness, spanning a continental nation. And when 60
通过悲情，而不是从远处观察。印刷品所需的批判能力——停下来、重读、质疑、比较的能力——被暂停了。屏幕成为了西奥多·阿多诺（Theodore Adorno）所说的文化工业的终极工具，一种大规模欺骗的机制，标准化的文化商品取代了真实的心理反思。而电视图像剥离了其真实的临场感——瓦尔特·本雅明（Walter Benjamin）称之为“灵光”（aura）——训练观众处于一种分心的接受状态。从40年代到70年代，三家电视网主导了美国电视，完成了一件前所未有的事情：跨越整个大陆国家的统一意识场。当60……
millions Americans watched the same program on the same evening, they were synchronizing in a way that no previous technology had enabled. But what kind of sharing was it? McCloughan noted that television was not primarily used to tell information or to convey stories. It conveyed itself. The medium was the message. What Americans were absorbing hour after hour was not the content of particular programs, but the form of television itself, the segmentation, the interruption, the rhythm of entertainment punctuated by advertising, the flow of drama, to comedy, to news, with no differentiation of cognitive mode. And the training was more significant than any particular ideology. The programs might have contained as just TV shows. Americans were learning to accept interruption as normal,
百万美国人在同一个晚上观看同一个节目时，他们正在以任何前代技术都无法实现的方式进行同步。但这是一种什么样的共享呢？麦克卢汉指出，电视主要不是用来传递信息或讲述故事的。它传递的是它自己。媒介即讯息。美国人每小时都在吸收的不是特定节目的内容，而是电视本身的形式：分段、中断、被广告打断的娱乐节奏、从戏剧到喜剧再到新闻的流动，没有任何认知模式的区分。这种训练比任何特定的意识形态都更重要。节目可能只是电视节目。美国人正在学习接受中断作为常态，
to tolerate fragmentation, to experience their own attention as a resource to be captured and sold. Television was not just a brainwashing device. You know, theorists like Theodore Aderno and Max Horkheimer, who had fled Nazi Germany for America, looked at this new mass media and they saw a terrifying trap. They called it the culture industry, and they pointed out correctly that the brutal economic tradeoff of television was that it turned human time and human attention into a raw commodity. Your relaxation was industrialized, and your eyeballs were harvested, quantified and sold to advertisers. But that didn't really affect the person doing the selling. They weren't being depleted of anything that they saw, and so it was fine. But while Adorno saw only mass deception, Walter Benjamin understood
容忍碎片化，将自己的注意力视为一种可以被捕获和出售的资源。电视不仅仅是一个洗脑装置。像西奥多·阿多诺和马克斯·霍克海默（Max Horkheimer）这些从纳粹德国逃到美国的理论家，看着这种新的大众媒体，看到了一个可怕的陷阱。他们称之为“文化工业”，并正确地指出，电视残酷的经济权衡在于，它将人类的时间和注意力变成了原始商品。你的放松被工业化了，你的眼球被收割、量化并卖给了广告商。但这并没有真正影响到那个卖东西的人。他们没有被剥夺任何他们看到的东西，所以这没关系。但当阿多诺只看到大规模欺骗时，瓦尔特·本雅明理解了……
something deeper about what happens when images are mechanically reproduced. Benjamin recognized that modern life is full of terrifying and alienating shocks, and that mass media, film and television, provide a safe and synchronized space for a fractured society to collectively process those shocks. And the atomized and isolated plastic oasis of the 1950 suburb, where the physical town had been bulldozed, television was the only community left. And when the old scripts of how to live, the village elders, the church, the extended family were stripped away, the screen provided a new type of script. Yet it was manufactured and it was
关于图像被机械复制时会发生什么，他理解得更深。本雅明认识到现代生活充满了可怕且异化的冲击，而大众媒体——电影和电视——为破碎的社会提供了一个安全且同步的空间来集体处理这些冲击。在50年代郊区那原子化且孤立的塑料绿洲中，当物理城镇被推倒时，电视是仅存的社区。当生活的旧脚本——村里的长者、教会、大家庭——被剥离时，屏幕提供了一种新的脚本。虽然它是制造出来的，而且是……
sponsored by soap companies, but it was necessarily a form of social training. It allowed you to feel. And while early programs like Father Knows Best and Leave It to Beaver established an idealized middle class paradigm to shield the psyche against the ideological terrors of the Cold War, the medium quickly expanded and the screen began to parade a vast array of archetypes right into the suburban living room. If you felt alienated, by the cheerful domestic servitude of the 1950s, anthology series like The Twilight Zone acted as a cultural subconscious, safely processing the shadow of profound anxiety, paranoia,
由肥皂公司赞助的，但它必然是一种社会训练形式。它让你能够去感受。虽然像《父亲最懂》（Father Knows Best）和《天才小麻烦》（Leave It to Beaver）这样的早期节目建立了一种理想化的中产阶级范式来保护心理免受冷战意识形态恐怖的影响，但媒介迅速扩张，屏幕开始将各种各样的原型直接带入郊区客厅。如果你对50年代欢快的家庭奴役感到疏离，《阴阳魔界》（The Twilight Zone）这样的选集系列充当了文化潜意识，安全地处理了深刻焦虑、偏执的阴影，
and the severe nerves that everyone was feeling. Television became the psychological architecture of the suburb. It also became the encounter point that most people would have with mental health or psychology itself. Shows like the Bob Newhart show in growing pains, often featured psychiatics. The therapeutic traditions that the human potential movement
以及每个人都能感受到的严重神经紧张。电视成为了郊区的心理架构。它也成为了大多数人接触心理健康或心理学本身的交汇点。像《鲍勃·纽哈特秀》（The Bob Newhart Show）和《成长的烦恼》（Growing Pains）这样的节目经常以精神病学为特色。人类潜能运动所开创的治疗传统……
had authored, required knowing yourself or sustained attention, discipline. And you had to stay with a feeling long enough to understand it. You had to want to know yourself. And you had to trace a pattern back through time. Television was training Americans in exact opposite habits. And so the dominant cultural force of the era clashed with the dominant psychological model. Television taught rapid switching, tolerance of contradiction,
需要了解自己或持续的注意力、纪律。你必须在一种感觉中停留足够长的时间去理解它。你必须想要了解自己。你必须追踪一个跨越时间的模式。电视正在训练美国人养成完全相反的习惯。因此，那个时代的统治性文化力量与统治性心理模型发生了冲突。电视教授快速切换、对矛盾的容忍、
the expectation of immediate emotional payoff, and the inability to sustain attention through difficulty. A culture formed by television would have trouble doing the kind of psychological work that insight-oriented therapy required. By the time that the cognitive behavioral revolution arrived in the late 1970s and 80s, the psychiatric and medical establishment used all of the New Age Hocum as an excuse to throw everything away that was developing during the human potential movement and keep it constantly relegated to the fringes of American Psych. To re-scientify therapy became their goal, and they orchestrated a massive purpose. Dr. Robert Spitzer and the architects of the DSM-3 drove psychiatry back towards a rigid medical model.
对即时情感回报的期望，以及无法在困难中维持注意力的能力。由电视塑造的文化将难以进行洞察导向型疗法所要求的那种心理工作。当认知行为革命在70年代末和80年代到来时，精神病学和医学界利用所有“新时代胡言乱语”作为借口，抛弃了人类潜能运动期间发展的一切，并将其持续贬低到美国心理学的边缘。让治疗“重新科学化”成为了他们的目标，他们策划了一个大规模的……罗伯特·斯皮策（Robert Spitzer）博士和DSM-3的设计师们将精神病学推回了僵化的医学模型。
We talked about that in the history of the DSM series. And Aaron Beck's CBT shifted the focus entirely towards the measurable, mechanical, behaviors that a hard science had always wanted. By the time the show Dallas aired in 1980, America was coming to terms with, as commentator Matt Crisman points out, that its East-Cloast elites that had been the guiding old money were being replaced by, the new money of the Texas oil fields. And the spectacle on TV on the show Dallas, who shot J.R. Was this way that America grieved,
我们在DSM系列的历史中谈到过这一点。亚伦·贝克（Aaron Beck）的CBT将焦点完全转移到了硬科学一直想要的、可衡量的、机械的行为上。当电视剧《达拉斯》（Dallas）在1980年播出时，正如评论员马特·克里斯曼（Matt Crisman）指出的那样，美国正在接受这样一个事实：那些作为指导性旧钱的东海岸精英正在被德克萨斯油田的新钱所取代。而电视节目《达拉斯》中的奇观——“谁枪击了J.R.”——是美国哀悼的一种方式，
the shock of the death of JFK, and a kind of national encounter group, all alone in their living rooms, but all feeling the same thing collectively. The television had become psychotherapy, as the nation grieved and accepted the passing of the torch from one group of billionaires to the next,
对肯尼迪遇刺的震惊，以及一种全国性的遭遇小组，所有人独自坐在客厅里，但都在集体感受同样的事情。电视已经变成了心理治疗，随着国家哀悼并接受了火炬从一群亿万富翁传递到下一群亿万富翁手中，
and also the collective trauma of the uncertainty of the American dream. by obsessing about a shooting in Dallas for an entire year. One of the prominent critics of the era, Dr. George Engel, warned in 1977 that psychiatry was in crisis because it was leaning too heavily into a reductive biomedical paradigm. He argued for a biopsychosocial model, one that would later be adapted by social work in America, warning that stripping the human context from suffering would be disastrous. And the establishment ignored that warning, and the re-scientification of therapy was complete.
以及美国梦不确定性的集体创伤，通过整整一年对达拉斯枪击案的痴迷。该时代的一位杰出评论家乔治·恩格尔（George Engel）博士在1977年警告说，精神病学正处于危机之中，因为它过于依赖还原论的生物医学范式。他主张采用“生物-心理-社会”模型，该模型后来被美国的社会工作所采用，警告说将人类背景从痛苦中剥离将是灾难性的。但建制派忽视了这一警告，治疗的重新科学化完成了。
And the release of the DSM3 removed the subjective agency from psychiatrists and transferred it to the diagnostic checklists of a formula-based diagnostic manual. The American counterculture had been inhabiting the psychological academic spaces more so than any other academic discipline. However, they failed to make any sort of material change towards their own goals. And the human potential movement had inadvertently reinforced the very individualism that it claimed to transcend. end. Finding yourself became the project, and yourself could be found without challenging the institution, the architecture, or the economic arrangements that shaped life. Binkley's insight here is that the liberation of the self from traditional constraints, which felt radical, actually served the emerging economic order perfectly. The neoliberalism that was beginning to take shape
DSM-3的发布剥夺了精神科医生的主观能动性，并将其转移到了基于公式的诊断手册的诊断清单上。美国反主流文化比任何其他学术学科都更多地占据了心理学学术空间。然而，他们未能朝着自己的目标做出任何实质性的改变。人类潜能运动无意中强化了它声称要超越的个人主义。寻找自我成为了项目，而无需挑战塑造生活的制度、架构或经济安排，就能找到自我。宾克利在这里的见解是，将自我从传统约束中解放出来——这感觉很激进——实际上完美地服务于正在形成的经济秩序。70年代开始形成的……
in the 1970s required exactly this kind of self, flexible, adaptable, and endlessly self-improving, consuming experiences as products. And the human potential movement taught people to feel liberated while remaining captured. It provided the aesthetic of freedom without the substance. And psychology, by focusing relentlessly on the individual, helped make this capture invisible. By the dawn of the 1980s, American culture had become a brutal filtering mechanism. The public was having a profound problem telling the difference between what was real and what could be sold. And the deeper, more holistic answers that therapy offered had failed to become a problem,
新自由主义恰恰需要这种自我：灵活、适应性强、不断自我提升，将体验作为产品消费。人类潜能运动教导人们在保持被捕获状态的同时感到解放。它提供了自由的审美，却没有自由的实质。而心理学通过无情地关注个人，帮助使这种捕获变得不可见。到了80年代初，美国文化已成为一种残酷的过滤机制。公众在区分什么是真实的、什么是可以出售的方面遇到了严重问题。而治疗所提供的更深层、更全面的答案未能成为一个……
that American life could sell. During the material surplus of the 1980s, the nation simply did not have to look at the depths anymore. The depression wasn't happening. It wasn't wartime. The void was still there, but the culture had developed sophisticated mechanisms for not seeing it. And this mass cultural blindness perfectly set the stage for the cognitive behavioral therapy revolution. The 1970s ended with the groundwork laid for a very different kind of psychology. It would be standardized, manualized, medication focused, insurance compatible, and it would speak the language of evidence as science preferred it. But the ghost of this era still haunt psychology today. After the transformation to the techno-libertarians,
美国生活可以出售的问题。在80年代的物质过剩期间，国家根本不需要再审视深渊了。萧条没有发生。那不是战时。空虚依然存在，但文化已经发展出复杂的机制来不去正视它。这种大众文化的盲目性完美地为认知行为疗法革命铺平了道路。70年代结束时，一种非常不同的心理学基础已经奠定。它将是标准化的、手册化的、以药物为中心的、与保险兼容的，并且它将使用科学所偏好的证据语言。但那个时代的幽灵至今仍困扰着心理学。在向科技自由意志主义者转型后，
Silicon Valley never stopped trying to co-opt the human soul and take over psychology. But now they're doing it through new footing, large language models and algorithmic AIs. When you hear a Silicon Valley billionaire talk about fusing quantum physics and AI to create God through microchips and that this is resonating with your soul, or one of the things that they see. recognize this as the shadow legacy of something like Eastland's ideas being co-opted. Terrorers of the cybernetic movement are still with us, the ones that people like Marshall McLuhan began to see the implications of in 1960. Deep psychological connection on the internet is an illusion, administered by a machine
硅谷从未停止试图收编人类灵魂并接管心理学。但现在他们通过新的基础——大语言模型和算法AI——来做这件事。当你听到硅谷亿万富翁谈论融合量子物理学和AI，通过微芯片创造上帝，并且这与你的灵魂产生共鸣时，或者他们看到的那些东西之一。请认识到这是像伊萨兰思想被收编后的阴影遗产。控制论运动的恐怖依然伴随着我们，马歇尔·麦克卢汉在1960年就开始看到其影响的那些东西。互联网上的深度心理连接是一种幻觉，由一台机器管理，
explicitly designed to extract and optimize your data. It's the same cybernetic trap but updated to the 21st century. The comfortable void is still sitting right in the middle of the living room. We haven't filled it. We've just built much more sophisticated screens so that we don't even see them anymore. More importantly, psychotherapy still struggles with an identity crisis wondering how much of a product it is, what its goals are, and how much it is able to butt heads with a contradicting culture or a technological paradigm of the time. One of the reasons for doing a series like this is that I don't see many of these problems as being new.
明确设计用于提取和优化你的数据。这是同样的控制论陷阱，只是更新到了21世纪。舒适的空虚依然坐在客厅的正中央。我们没有填补它。我们只是建造了更复杂的屏幕，以至于我们甚至不再看到它们了。更重要的是，心理治疗仍然在身份危机中挣扎，想知道它有多少是产品，它的目标是什么，以及它能在多大程度上与矛盾的文化或当时的技术范式抗衡。做这样一个系列的原因之一是，我不认为这些问题中的许多是新的。
I see many of them as problems left by other generations and kick down the real. road for us now. Every 10 years, mainstream media will pretend that a mental health crisis is a sudden, mysterious modern phenomenon, but it's not. It's the exact same problem with no name that Breddy Ferdin diagnosed in 1963. Only now the surplus wealth is gone, and the American dream has been stripped for parts, and the safety net has been completely dissolved. The baby boomers refused to look at this void. They couldn't. They were too close to it. And they took Miletown and they watched sitcom patriarchs tell them that everything was fine. And Generation X tried to mock the void with irony, but they couldn't build anything to replace it. The millennials tried to
我认为它们中的许多是前几代人留下的问题，并被踢到了我们现在的路上。每隔10年，主流媒体就会假装心理健康危机是一个突然的、神秘的现代现象，但事实并非如此。这正是贝蒂·弗里丹（Betty Friedan）在1963年诊断出的那个“没有名字的问题”。只是现在剩余财富消失了，美国梦被拆解变卖，安全网已完全溶解。婴儿潮一代拒绝正视这种空虚。他们不能。他们离它太近了。他们服用安定（Miltown），看着情景喜剧中的家长告诉他们一切都好。X世代试图用讽刺来嘲弄这种空虚，但他们无法建立任何东西来取代它。千禧一代试图……
hack the void with side hustles, self-optimization, and something that felt more authentic than Best Buy and Appleby's by building breweries and hanging Edison classic light bulbs on the wall with extension cords, completely exhausting themselves in the process. And now Gen Z is coming in paralyzed by the weight of the next thing as they struggle to exist in the stream of technology and algorithmic consciousness as it currently exists. We're still inside the exact same architectural and psychological trap. We just happen to be the ones who are currently holding the bag. We're being forced to solve the terrifying structural collapse of the 1950s that was medicated, and the 1960s that tried to scream and self-indulge its way away. In the 1980s, it got buried under cognitive checklists and consumer
通过副业、自我优化来“黑”进这种空虚，并通过建造啤酒厂、用延长线在墙上挂爱迪生经典灯泡，来构建一种感觉比百思买（Best Buy）和Applebee's更真实的东西，在这个过程中完全耗尽了自己。现在Z世代进场了，被下一件事的重量压得瘫痪，因为他们努力在当前存在的科技和算法意识流中生存。我们仍然处于完全相同的建筑和心理陷阱中。我们只是恰好是目前拿着这个烂摊子的人。我们被迫解决50年代被药物掩盖的、60年代试图通过尖叫和自我放纵来逃避的恐怖结构性崩溃。在80年代，它被埋在认知清单和消费……
credit, but no solution was ever found. The alienation was never cured, and the open-air asylum's were never closed. The death of meaning was never addressed and the psychological architects of the 20th century just kept building better screens and prescribing better pills, and now better algorithms, deferring the collapse for one more decade and leaving us to navigate the ruins of their avoidance. And so the question persists, what is psychology's role in this process? Is it supposed to sit back and watch? Is it supposed to offer a solution? And how much is it supposed to diagnose the current culture that it operates within. These used to be questions that people sat around and encountered groups and tried to confront, and now they're just managing collapse,
信贷之下，但从未找到解决方案。异化从未被治愈，露天精神病院从未被关闭。意义的死亡从未被解决，20世纪的心理建筑师们只是不断建造更好的屏幕，开出更好的药丸，现在是更好的算法，将崩溃推迟了十年，留给我们去在他们逃避的废墟中航行。所以问题依然存在：心理学在这个过程中扮演什么角色？它是应该坐视不管吗？它是应该提供解决方案吗？它应该在多大程度上诊断它所处的当前文化？这些曾经是人们坐在遭遇小组里试图面对的问题，而现在他们只是在管理崩溃，
managing a system that no one is trying to fix anymore. If this feels like endless looping, it may not be. It may be a patient repeating a pattern on a couch that it needs to recognize, and before it can change it, it must bring recognition and awareness to the pattern itself. Each generation genuinely believed that they were breaking the cycle. The hippies thought they were over-throwing the behaviorists. The cognitive therapist thought that they were curing the hippies, but they were all just running on the exact same wheel, and they were just upgrading the software of their own containment. And this is the ultimate tragedy of American psychology. It became the mechanism for endless deferral. It trained us to constantly optimize ourselves for a society that
管理一个已经没有人试图去修复的系统。如果这感觉像无休止的循环，那可能并非如此。这可能是一个病人躺在沙发上重复着一种它需要识别的模式，在它能改变它之前，它必须将识别和意识带给模式本身。每一代人都真诚地相信他们正在打破循环。嬉皮士认为他们正在推翻行为主义者。认知治疗师认为他们正在治愈嬉皮士，但他们都只是在同一个轮子上奔跑，他们只是在升级自己禁锢的软件。这就是美国心理学的终极悲剧。它成为了无休止推迟的机制。它训练我们不断地为一个社会优化自己，而这个社会……
was fundamentally broken rather than asking us to fix society itself, even while it was asking us to talk about fixing society. And now the loop is spinning faster, and we're not just to be. facing modern mental health crisis, we're now facing the accumulated compound interest of 80 years of deferred psychological debt. The system keeps looping, offering us mindfulness apps to cure our existential exhaustion, and AI language models to cure our profound isolation. It's the same deferral, just deliberate at fiber optic speed. Technologies that were created for connection have bred profound isolation, and psychology will continue to remain in this loop until it starts to confront that tension. And until we realize that we're trapped in this loop,
从根本上说是破碎的，而不是要求我们去修复社会本身，即使它在要求我们谈论修复社会。现在循环转得更快了，我们不仅面临现代心理健康危机，我们现在面临的是80年推迟的心理债务所积累的复利。系统不断循环，为我们提供正念应用程序来治愈我们的存在主义疲惫，提供AI语言模型来治愈我们的深刻孤立。这是同样的推迟，只是以光纤速度进行。为连接而创造的技术滋生了深刻的孤立，心理学将继续留在这个循环中，直到它开始面对那种张力。直到我们意识到我们被困在这个循环中，
There is not a techno fix for this problem, and we can't self-actualize or compute our way out of the structural nightmare The ghost will remain in the machine and the void will keep waiting for us in the center of the living room A old film flicker on a cracked white wall Smoking in your father's coat Dust in the beam like a cheap disco History looping through your machines your Your soft set get carried through the tangled wires cold machines Warm ghosts you sing and something in me shakes
这个问题没有技术修复方案，我们无法通过自我实现或计算来摆脱这种结构性噩梦。幽灵将留在机器中，空虚将继续在客厅中央等待我们。旧电影在破裂的白墙上闪烁，穿着你父亲的外套抽烟，灰尘在光束中像廉价迪斯科，历史在你的机器中循环，你柔软的身体被带过纠缠的电线，冰冷的机器，温暖的幽灵，你歌唱，我内心有什么在颤抖。
I'm holding on to everywhere we were not mistakes There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我紧紧抓住我们不是错误的每一个地方。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。